all right so
um i'm going to show you this article
here
uh share this is
a what does this say here
twitch keep going what's her name ameru
i don't know how to pronounce this
am amor athen whatever the hell that is
she's a twitch streamer this is a
classic example of a thirst trap
that gets the attention of so many men
today and i'm going to click through on
a few things
here and throw them up up on the screen
to give you guys an idea that may not be
familiar with simping
the gravity of this problem um so this
is just a quick
um article this is from april
21 so this is earlier this year i think
the same
girl was also written in an article last
year as well because that's when i first
came across this idea that
or this notion anyway that guys are um
throwing money at women for sleeping
literally they're they're throwing money
at women
while they take their eight hours of
sleep in the evening and they're earning
money in
literally in their sleep they're getting
money thrown at them while they're in
bed
and this is just a quick screenshot of
it over here
um and there's like little goals and
steps that she's trying to encourage
people to uh hit
and you know she gives a little an extra
hour of sleep or an extra 20 minutes of
sleep or something like that
but it's big it's big big business okay
like this is
this is a serious thing like to give you
an idea of
how popular this this chick is where's
her uh
instagram does it come up here if i go
like that no gotta remove
and share the screen again
give me a second here sure screen window
boom
boom okay so this is her instagram now
i had to scroll down quite a bit uh to
get to a picture that i could put up
with comments that wouldn't get me
banned because most of the stuff
at the top of the page it's pretty
revealing like
you know probably cause problems on
youtube but what i wanted to show you
here was the comments
okay because this is what typical
simping type of behavior looks like
um you know usually a bunch of kissy
faces trophies and hardy's and all that
flames you will see women
in there simping as well for her but not
because
they have hopes of being intimate with
her it's because they're basically
trying to drive
traffic to their pages so you will see
that from time to time
but for the most part most of this stuff
is all dudes omg so perfect i love you
in red
this is two tigger six eight eight six
i'm sure that she's tripping over
herself to go
to this dude's place right now sexy red
marry me marquito s87 this is flat out
simping behavior
and it is endless you know you can go
beautiful
heart emojis be my valentine
these are all you know simpy ass you
know type of behaviors they're all
they're all looking for
and i'm sure a lot of these guys are
sliding into her dms
um they're probably regulars that
contribute to twitch streams and all
sort of stuff like that
um all the same stuff hashtag wife
status
woah endless and you know a lot of guys
wonder why women today have
have like an over inflated uh sense of
self-worth
um this is a twitch um thirst trap of
course
um you know enhanced let's say because
when you look at the links and stuff
she's obviously had some work done
but um let's just scroll up to the top
over here to the links
let's see if we can get her stream this
is where you get into the problematic
photographs
all right uh so she says twitch streamer
news stories of vr exclusive content
link tree yeah shocking she's got an
only fans
uh twitch is all the way down at the
bottom which you think would be the
bread and butter
but let's see what she's doing right now
oh it says live
i can't run that because it's a
ad it's going to be a hit anyway
i'll put it back up when the ad uh
i don't know i guess it's a pre-roll ad
they do those on twitch as well
but believe it or not okay there we go
so she's actually live right now
believe it or not she's been streaming
for seven hours and 25 minutes
and again you can see here all the
simping
you know hey beautiful so gorgeous my
pudding pop blah blah blah
13 366
guys are sitting here obviously i'm
watching it too now so i'm
67. um with all you guys along with me
but
you get the point there's a lot of
people that feed this
uh beast it's endless
um she's got links here to all the like
this chick
has got to be making 200 300 000
i mean if she knows what she's doing
she's got to be making a quarter million
a month
at least because she's getting donations
from dudes on twitch
she's getting only fans memberships
she's got um
what else she got on here twitch
donation snapchat i don't even know what
else she's monetized she's probably got
sponsors or products as well that she
sells
but you get the idea right this sort of
stuff
is what feeds the sims you know this is
what they're looking for this is what
they want
why do guys do it so let's keep moving
on here so guys do this stuff because
it's easy safe and comfortable
bottom line is they have a total lack of
self-respect for themselves
they don't have a real purpose in life
meaning
they probably haven't even found what
their gift is
let alone what it what what talents they
have
because simping is not a talent it's
certainly not a gift it's
it's a distraction that keeps guys away
from getting on a purpose
that keeps guys away from uh
you know basically releasing their gift
you know on the world simping is not a
gift
you know it's not a talent um they do it
because they think being a nice guy will
get them intimacy
and if you're one of the guys that any
of these things resonate with
i'd recommend that you start by reading
this book here which is
which is always linked in my amazon
bookstore but
it is a good read and helps get your
head squared away with the covert
contracts that men
essentially make up in their head
between themselves and women
for example a covert contract that a
cent might make is if i donate enough
money to this lady
she's going to maybe fall in love with
me want to go out with me
at some point acknowledge that i'm
unique special or something like that
and um you know want to jump into it
with them but
uh these covert contracts never execute
right like they never come to fruition
it's it's
it's really an exhaustive process that
most of these dudes go through
the teaching that comes to
boys today one of the big problems is
about 43 percent
of children are raised in single mother
households
and mothers are great at being mothers
but they suck at being fathers
and instilling masculine virtues
especially in boys
so a lot of these guys um like a lot of
the guys that i talk to
that struggle with women they usually
ended up coming from a single mother
household
could be divorced could be dad was a
loser could be widowed could be any
number of things could be mom pushed him
out of the household right
um and these kids are left with just
feminine energy growing up
it's taught in parenting it's taught in
school you know
boys are taught in school uh to be so
righteous and to always bend the knee to
a female first primary social order
media government it's like everything
that comes at
guys today is basically teaching them to
be
nice guys to be weak uh
to bend the knee and always placate
basically white knighting type of
behavior
you know i'm all there for the feminine
imperative because that's what's going
to get me the girls
doesn't go down that way never executes
that way
you